بحسب التلفزيون الرسمي التركي هو زلزال
جديد ضرب نفس المنطقه التي ضربها الزلزال
الاول لكن منطقه قريبه في ولايه كهرمان
مرعش هذه المره في منطقه غوز بنار في
ولايه كهرمان مرعش زلزال جديد بقوه 7.6
على مقياس
7.6 درجات على مقياس ريختر قبل حوالي ساعه
من الان او اقل من ساعه على حسب او بالضبط
قبل ساعه من الان في هذه المنطقه
ليزيد اليزيد من المتاعب التي تواجه فرق
الانقاذ اذا
زلزالان في نفس المنطقه في ولايه كهرمان
مرعش كرمان مرعش كلا الزلزالان بقوه
تجاوزت 7.6 خلال ساعات قليله فقط او تفصل
بين
توقيت الزلزلين
اذا هذا كما ذكرت سيزيد من المعاناه طبعا
نتيجه هذا الزلزال وصل صدى الزلزال او
تاثير الزلزال ايضا الى ولايه غازي عنتاب
كما تحدثنا قبل قليل
العشرات بل الالاف من الاهالي الذين كانوا
يختبرون في عده مناطق خرجوا الى الشوارع
خوفا من هذا الزلزال والهزات الارتداديه
التي ستليه حتى الان منذ الصباح وحتى
اليوم اكثر من 110 هزات ارتداديه طلبت عشر
ولايات تركيا هي الولايات الجنوبيه في
تركيا وهي التي تضررت من الزلزال الاول
ولا نعلم حتى الان الانباء عن مدى الضرر
الذي خلفه الزلزال الثاني لذلك نتوقع او
السلطات تتوقع الاسوء وتامل ان تصل الفرق
الانقاذ بسرعه الى اماكن الاماكن المتضرره
الرئيس التركي كان يتحدث عن اكثر من تسعه
عن اكثر من 9000 شخص مت او من فرق الانقاذ
يواصلون العمل
للوصول الى الانقاض وانقاذ العالقين تحت
الانقاض لكن يامل الرئيس التركي والسلطات
التركيه في حال تم
استكمال وصول فرق الانقاذ وطواقم الانقاذ
الى المواقع المدمره بتكثيف عمليات البحث
والوصول الى ناجين اكثر وبالتالي تخفيف
من وطاه هذه هذه الكارثه على تركيا طبعا
الرئيس التركي قال انها الاسوا منذ عام